more new local water Cuts could be on
the horizon if a new bill in the Nevada
legislature is passed but some of Clark
County's 15 000 septic or well users say
they can't afford it Ryan mathey
explains the Dilemma
Nevada's water problems just won't flush
we will need to continue to use less
water along with everyone else on the
Colorado River lawmakers considering a
new bill to do that ab220 a water
conservation Bill seeking to limit
residential and commercial water usage
in southern Nevada
part of doing that requiring some on
septic to connect to sewer but only
those within 400 feet of a community
water system says Southern Nevada water
authorities Andy Bellinger the property
may be within 400 feet but it would take
800 feet to get to the to the Sewer that
person would not be affected and if past
the deadline wouldn't be for another 30
years but with the Valley's booming
development some on septic concerned
they would eventually fall into that
requirement and not be able to afford it
this is too much of a burden for these
targeted homeowners as written now the
government would be required to pay only
for half the conversion with the
possibility to cover more a cost that
democratic congresswoman Susie Lee said
could be between 20 000 to 200 000 and a
price some are not willing to pay this
cost is not something that we can afford
it does feel like we're being held
hostage to a certain degree you have to
have consideration for these older
people
that are on a fixed income are no way
going to have the money to get that done
now the Southern Nevada Water Authority
says it is working to get state and
federal dollars to cover some conversion
costs above 50 percent now for context a
similar conversion program gave well
owners 50 to 85 percent of the cost
according to snwa but this bill has no
cap on just how much it would pay for
more on this store use your cell phone
camera to scan this QR code on your
screen it will take you to 8newsnow.com
where the story will be on the front
page and if you missed the QR code we'll
have it for you again in 10 minutes